I probably would make a time machine.
I would make medicine for the sick.
I'd probably invent something new.
If I could have an extra five years to live,...
You said five, right?
Five years?
It's a long time.
...I would try to fix everything I did bad.
I would bring my uncle back 'cause I miss him very much.
I would get more hamsters.
I would probably wanna go looking for dark matter.
I think I'd go looking for aliens.
If I could live an extra five years,...
...I was thinking about making like a helicopter, like a wooden helicopter,...
...but I don't have any wood.
I wanna go check out the moon sometime.
I'd probably teach my sister not to hate tuna.
I would try to invent a machine that lets you run at light speed.
If I have five more extra years to live,...
...I would be the boss of all the chipmunks.
I don't really know, I think I'd do anything.
Why are you asking me that?